okay i have a few sort of like short
trumpy stories to go over with you guys
these these are mostly comedic elements
but uh they're also just sad and
pathetic and more about just the sad sad
state of trumpism and republicans in the
united states which by the way they
could be in a sad state and still win in
2022 and in fact i think it's quite
plausible so first and foremost um you
guys know about donald trump i'm
guessing you also know about this guy
mike lindell we know him as mike pillow
he's the ceo of my pillow and mike
lindell has been one of the main
conspiracy delusionists
delusionists or delusionalists i guess
is the question who has been
basically since the november 2020
election saying in december this thing
will be overturned by january 6th it
will be overturned by january 20th it
will be overturned it'll be march trump
will be back in office april it'll be by
the summer it'll be by the end of summer
the latest i think is that it'll be by
thanksgiving but clearly that is
not going to happen and maybe he's
forgotten about that
this is so weird and bizarre
apparently mike pillow
has recorded
what they are describing as an exclusive
blockbuster interview with donald trump
and
trump's wearing a tuxedo in the
interview i don't know why i'm guessing
there's some explanation maybe this was
done at an event time who who really
knows um and
pillow is promoting lindell is promoting
this interview
as
so earth-shattering that when he plays
it the week of thanksgiving
the american people are just going to
rise up and demand that donald trump
reinstating be reinstated
and uh i'm going to look at just a
preview of this interview it's
completely off the rails take a look at
this go back to november 4th and we all
live this twilight zone
i always say like there was an old
saying you know if a tree falls in the
forest and no one heard it did it really
fall well then the media tells us there
is no forest yeah i mean that's where it
was i love trump saying yeah as
as if he understands what pillow is
talking about here um let's continue
back in november and december and and
now you know we were yeah i know but we
were all living in this twilight zone
you were living there with us and
but then you had all the betrayals and
attacks on you that escalated to a whole
other level
and eric told me once that you said
right before you were going down that
escalator to make your famous
announcement can you imagine that you
said
well we're going to find out now who our
true friends are
and and i never forgot that he said that
to me
and you know it was everyone out there
since that time we've all been praying
for you for you to have strength and
my question is what does give you the
emotional strength
really a hard-hitting blockbuster
interview as you can imagine um so it's
sort of unclear what trump is even
really doing right now he may be you
know there's this idea that he's
preparing for some kind of big
2022 participation of sorts in the
midterms
uh he's off twitter
we don't really know what it is that
he's doing other than publishing these
bizarre
statements so just to give you an idea
of what he's been up to an example
statement trump published to his website
the unselect committee of politically
ambitious hacks
continues to subpoena people wanting to
know about those protesting on january
6th the insurrection which took place
during the presidential election of
november 3rd so trump is now saying the
insurrection was the election that he
claims was stolen
there is so much proof but the fake news
media refuses to print it or show it in
any way read the arizona report look at
wisconsin pennsylvania georgia numerous
other states nothing's happening there
nothing's happening in those in those
states so trump with still insisting on
this stuff and at this point is it even
to raise money i don't know trump i i
was going to say tweeting but posting
blog posts
where he says look at what they found in
georgia 74 counties in georgia are
missing ballot images
okay
trump uh posting i i keep wanting to say
tweeting an article from the daily
signal claiming that 26 000 dead people
are still registered to vote in michigan
now remember guys we've talked about
this dead people voting thing
just because someone's registered and
died since being registered doesn't mean
they voted in michigan the dead people
voting thing has been widely widely
debunked
and then trump attacking liz cheney
with an approval rating at 19 in wyoming
people are wise to liz cheney she is a
threat to free and fair elections which
are the cornerstone of our country
because she caved so easily on the crime
of the century meaning
the fact that
joe biden actually won the election
this is sad
but i think we shouldn't underestimate
the reality
that there is still energy behind this
guy
and last week's election results
combined with whatever it is that trump
may have planned for the midterms could
very well lead to republicans cleaning
up in 2022 taking the house
taking the senate
winning more state governorships and
having almost democrats would have the
white house but having almost total
control of the country for at least a
period of a couple of years during which
they could do a ton a ton a ton of
damage
one of our sponsors is nebia who have
developed the most impressive shower
head i've ever seen it was designed by
former nasa engineers who spent years
researching how to save water and what
they created the nebia bimon spa shower
uses 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head but with an 81
percent more powerful spray and they do
this by using atomized droplets that
rinse soap and shampoo off faster than
any shower head i've ever used i
installed nebia by moan spa shower in my
bathroom at home took five minutes to
set up i've been using it for about a
year
i'm in and out of the shower way faster
because of that powerful spray but again
it's helping the planet and your wallet
by using 45 percent less water than a
traditional shower head nebia is
currently offering free shipping in the
u.s on pre-order products and for all
other nebbia products like the shower
head which starts at just 199 you'll get
10 off when you go to nebia.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
link is underneath this video